[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
isabelle fox productrice de sa fabia
léger
[Musique]
on se trouve alassane ce plan en fait la
firme la polo charges qu'on appelle
aussi ça fera mal pour le côté safran
j'avais perdu mon emploi suite à une
restructuration mais j'étais vraiment
rendu à une période de ma carrière où je
voulais changer de métier puis
l'agriculture m'avait toujours intéressé
j'ai vu le reportage de pour safran qui
était une productrice zaffran ici au
québec on n'a pas fait d'études de
marché c'était vraiment tout cas qu'on
se dit bon on va faire en sorte que les
québécois découvrent le safran découvre
le goût
[Musique]
le sapin c'est les pistes qui coûte
l'afficheur au monde et puis c'est dû au
fait que la majorité de la culture s'est
fait de façon manuelle vos plantes et on
veut accueillir on va désherber on voit
après quelques années il faut sortir les
bulbes les diviser les replanter ça
prend entre 150 et 200 fleurs pour faire
un gramme de safran
mais par contre un gramme de safran peut
faire environ 150 portions individuelles
selon les types de recettes que l'on
emploie on sait pousser faut tout
relativiser en bout de ligne pour ce qui
est de la plaie l'or rouge
allez soyez une formation en france il
ya aussi le mapaq au printemps dernier
qui ont fait venir un expert français
pour nous former si le québec
ça nous donne des pistes dans le futur
pour adapter la production aux
conditions québécoise
les deux prochaines années sont pour
déterminer ce que c'est via le safran on
va parler de quoi
j'ai fait quand même conscient que pour
côtoyer des agriculteurs du nombre
d'heures que ces gens là au maillet
destin voudrait que c'est plus le côté
monétaire qui me surprend à quel point
on peut il fourre tout nous donner c'est
de l'investissement qu'on fait
présentement on est confiants en nos
projets en ce qu'on fait puis
présentement on ne verrait pas au pharos
lui mr fini je ne peux pas prédire
présentement qu'on devra d'aussi belles
cueillettes qu en iran ou comme arak
mais on va essayer de faire de notre
mieux
[Musique]